якого міста ти живеш в цій країні але
при цьому настільки зневажаєш цю країну
що не паришся абсолютно більш кримських
татар давно вже сама визначились і бачу
себе громадянами України в мене моя на
увазі точно до 14-го року було таке
враження що ну служитель ті хто нічого
більше не може хіба ми можемо зараз так
подумати про нашу армію ні якщо ми
хочемо верховенство права маємо
виховувати таких майбутніх
суддів самого дитинства Сьогодні ми
спілкуємося з українським режисером
військовослужбовцем культурним та
громадським діячем Артемом сайтаблаєвим
Артема Вітаю вас раді зустрічі І ви нас
запросили зустрітися у Кримському домі
який ви очолюєте з 2017 року чи це місце
дає вам це Відчуття того дому Криму який
ви свого часу втратили
ну це скоріш за атмосферою яку створює
команда ну і зараз ми знаходимося в
кімнаті де власне залишили ми частину
Великого такого проекту
йол щоб в прикладі української шлях
відкриття цієї виставки відбулося
напередодні ну буквально там за декілька
місяців за два місяці до початку
широкомасштабного навала А ось і
Кримський дім був власне як один простір
такий тематично і за стилем Так Ми
намагаємося зробити так щоб це
відчуття дому було у кожного хто
потрапляє сюди тут і 150 моїх студентів
не одночасно і це добре займається Я маю
на увазі
і ми завжди і їм і всім і відвідувачами
нашим друзям і гостям кажемо я
намагаємося зробити так щоб вони дійсно
відчували тут
Ну скажімо так той спокій
який напевно нам всім
хочу потрібен хоча б на той час коли ви
відвідуєте Кримський дім коли
веанонсували свій нещодавний фільм
Мирний 21 Ви обмовилися що прем'єру
цього року ви вже бачите і плануєте в
бахчисараті як кожного року планую
але зараз будучи військовослужбовцем ЗСУ
ви об'єктивно бачити цю можливість цього
літа приїхати в Крим і прем'єру цього
фільму зробити там ну
відповідаючи на питання бачити Я можу
взяти на себе функцію ну такого
надзвичайного обізнаного військового
експерта звичайно я таким не є те що
стосується моєї мрії і віри в те що ми
повернемось і
Я дуже сподіваюся що все йде до того що
повернення фактично Криму до складу
України відбудеться скоріше і набагато
скоріше ніж ми навіть мали очікувати от
Все я вірю голова Української розвідки
подано також казав таку річ цитую Крим
буде повернуто комбінованим шляхом і
силою і дипломатією як ви переживаєте
емоційно той факт що рано чи пізно там
відбудеться певна силове зіткнення
збройних сил України і окупантів і ваші
рідні будуть там в цей час
там вже
[музика]
цей час не тільки
цей рік який пройшов
[музика]
весь період ці сучасної війни онука з
донькою вони в іншій країні ця 8 рік там
дави абсолютно праві Я знаю як
налаштований
ті хто є мені
близькими рідними дорогим
Ось і є тільки прошу Всевишнього щоб
нічого з ними не сталося тому що вони
від себе роблять все для того щоб яку
можна
прискорити
повернення України
в Крим і Криму до України чи були за всі
ці роки у ваших рідних які лишаються там
певні проблеми оскільки ви публічно з
проукраїнською позицією виступаєте як
медійна особа як їм там жилося вони не
мають відповідати там перед окупантом
Звичайно це не є якимось аргументом для
окупаційної влади
Ось і так я знаю що
кожного разу
за нагодою
моїм родичам нагадують
і про неї висловлювання і про мою
позицію нагадують що ви маєте на увазі
як їм це нагадує там Ну наприклад коли
ми діти перетинали кордон так званий між
Кримом і Україною він постійно
нагадували що можливо там останній раз
ми вас пропустимо до батька і дитина
вітання йому в лапках Передавайте Ну і
Коли викликають і кажуть щоб
поговорили зі мною щоб я менше взагалі
висловлювався з приводу окупантів
з приводу має категоричною
позиції по відношенню до
Російської Федерації яка окупувала і
Крим і частину Луганської і Донецької
області Але вони мене самі підтримують
кажуть про те що
мовчати я не маю права Як ви гадаєте
Якими мають бути міжнародні гарантії
безпеки для Криму в складі України
НАТО і
в Європейському Союзі але в першу чергу
НАТО звичайна річ сучасна професійна
українська армія
міцна прозора економіка
гарного освіта
верховенства права і невідворотність
покарання за скоєння злочин Ну ми ж
знаємо з історії та
як іноді покидьки вдало ховаються але і
зараз на часи Другої світової війни
ось тому вірю сподіваюсь що
жоден злочинець
не зможе уникнути покарання український
мусат в тому числі чому ні ви вірите що
така організація може вже існувати
можливо
певною мірою так як має бути вирішене
мовне питання у звільненому Криму
зокрема в контексті гори-інтеграції який
статус матиме кримськотатарська мова
який статус матиме українська безперечно
державна мова це в першу чергу і всі
офіційні організації
заклади всі засоби масової інформації
сферообслуговування
публічна діяльність громадських діячів і
тим більше людей які працюють на
держслужби обов’язково знання
української якщо казати конкретну Крим
Я мрію про набуття
тієї мрії якою живуть татари вже багато
десятиріччя а саме національне
територіальна автономія у складі України
виходячи з цього із визнаного
міжнародним правом права корінних
народів на самовизначення
абсолютно більш кримських татар давно
вже сама визначилися і бачить себе
громадянами України і навіть якщо вони
мовчать в Криму то це мовчання дуже
голосно три четверті тих політичних
в'язнів яких заарештували в Криму є саме
кримськими татарами і це чітко
демонструє позицію кримських гітару по
відношенню до окупантів до окупантів І
власне їх бачення
своего майбутнього в складі якої держави
тобто знання консаторської мови я
розглядав як ну я пропонував її
обов'язково для держ чиновника тому що
якого
біси ти живеш в цій країні тобто тебе
влаштовує в цей країні Скажімо так
система координат дав якої
люди
вибрали своє право тут жити Ти
користуєшся цим але при цьому настільки
зневажаєш цю країну що не паришся Да
потому що Ну добре було б знати взагалі
тому що це не є подвигом це звичайно
повагою до України в якої ти мешкаєш І
наприклад той самий Швейцарії як люблять
згадувати деякі персонажі прихильники
Русского Мира ну мовляли чотири
державної мови да все так але вони
забувають додати що якщо ти хочеш з
Франко говоряща вода кантону
влаштуватися скажімо в етало говорящий
да або
[музика]
скантон де
державною мовою є німецька мова
ти не влаштовуєшся там на роботу якщо не
знаєш мови яка є державна у цьому
контоні Ну тобто першу веде серед різних
мова про те щоб давати життя мові яка є
мовою цієї держави
в побуті розмовляє будь-якою зараз ви
чудово говорити українською але перший
час після анексії ви ще говорили
російською навіть в інтерв'ю це 17-й рік
ось коли настала та точка коли ви
відчули в собі і змогу і бажання і
потребу вже остаточно попрощатись з
російською в публічному просторі
так трошки важкувато точно визначити Ну
приблизно напевно рік 19-й десь А що це
були за відчуття От і що вас наштовхнуло
все я вже маю це
спектр твоїх власних почуттів і бажання
по-перше відчуваєш що ще
на диво
у Криму пристосована
розмовляти
різними мовами в тому числі в тому числі
української це почуття
власного такого виклику і бажання бути
дотичним до
цих
процесів скажімо відновлення
контексту цієї країни землі
це не заважає абсолютно мені бути
консультативним мусульманом абсолютно і
це ж Хоча і невелика але все ж таки і
перемога над
власним комплексом особливо коли
починаєш тільки розмовляти ви пішли в
ЗСУ спочатку повномасштабного вторгнення
І у вас не було абсолютно ніякого
досвіду ви Людина зі сфери творчості які
функції ви там виконуєте зараз і тоді от
без такого
ми разом з моїм колегом колегою і
товаришем Олексієм тритенко 25 февраля
ми змогли
ближче до вечора знайти батальйон де ще
йшов запис до складу батальйону це
батальйон територіальної оборони ввечері
25 Ми були вже в лісі під гостомелем
з зброєю ось потім через три дні
відбулась ротація і мене майже одразу
призначили
також офіцер на 206 батальйону ми
створили команду доволі потужною і якщо
я не помиляюсь через там пару тижнів
фото світлини наших бійців і побратимів
і по сестер з'явилися на шпальтах
героїтерс
nrpost
Guardian 9 квітня разом з батальйоном
вирушили на нові місця
виконання своїх службових обов'язків а
саме місто Миколаїв були там до
липня да ну майже до серпня місяця
Минулого року Потім був за наказом
командира нашої бригади
а призначений тимчасово виконуючим
обов'язки
керівника служби зв'язків з
громадськістю бригади а з жовтня місяця
за наказом командуючого сил про збройних
сил України призначений художнім
керівником
колективу який складається з
військовослужбовців сил територіальної
оборони з різних підрозділів які в
цивільному житті Були
операторами режисерами акторами для того
щоб відзняти таку певну аналогію сил
територіальної оборони
про всі сили територіальної оборони це
такий
Ну скажімо так колективний портрет
військового підрозділу в якому
проходять свою службу за власним
абсолютно власним бажанням тому що сили
територіальної оборони - це апріорі
добровольця я по професії електрики Я
водій Я вообще пенсионер юрист працював
художником-постановником тому я проти
рейс священик батько три сина Ми як
родина навіть
схожі в одному в своїх бажаннях там
боронитися захищати своє нещодавно
відбулась відбувся допрем'єрний показ
така Ну презентація того доробку які ми
разом з командою зробили
про медіа Так Ми назвали нашу Ну поки що
всередині себе
цей підрозділ який в свою чергу
займається гетьма напрямками в першу
чергу створення документального серіалу
за наказом команду від щиро а також
паралельно з цим це і освітні програми і
спеціальні
програма як наприклад дослідження
проблематики актуальності скажімо
жіночих бронежилерів маєш робити по
максимуму те що можеш з тим що маєш там
де ти є Ну цей досвід який ви отримали в
перші місяці війни і будучи наближеним
до всіх воєнних подій які відбувалися
безпосередньо на фронті які от найбільш
такі моменти вам запам'ятались можливо
змінили вас з середини те що стосується
змін які я сам відчуваю по собі Ну
напевно став більш
нетерпими
до певних проявів
людської нафтури Скажімо так ніяких
самих Я не люблю дилетантів
і
переконався в тому що
особливо коли це стосується
знаходження там де кожна прийнята
рішення або не прийняте рішення
безпосередньо стосується життя людей
делеканти немає бути не мають бути тими
хто приймає рішення
Хвала всевишньому і українському
народові
все ж таки переважно більшість тих людей
хто приймає рішення
адекватні професійні люди що
заповнимосштабної війни дуже гостро
стоїть питання підготовки бійців або не
було дилетантів так як ви кажете і як
відбувається мобілізація ваш досвід
служби з
військовослужбовцями
військовослужбовцями ви бачите Який
рівень підготовки і чи дійсно там є
недостатньо Готові бійці бій чи ні Чи це
все ж таки міф або якась Пропаганда
Напевно точно є випадки коли знову ж
таки
завдячуючи в лаках делітантам хтось із
побратимів або по сестер потрапляє на
лінію зіткнення за безпосередньо в зону
бойових дій непідготовленим але
я знаю точно що абсолютно більшість
проходить навчання
інша справа яку
рівня тому що ну
[музика]
за три місяці
точно важко стати спецпризначенцем
цим люди займаються все життя але
мати знання про такмет на тактичну
медицину
[музика]
мати вміння
поводитися зі зброєю і розуміти
як найбільш ефективно і застосовувати
точно можна вчитися і таке навчання
відбувається злагодження і підрозділів і
більш великих військових
колективів на іротних і батальйонних А
навчання відбувається і в тому числі Ми
якраз
знімаючи документальну стрічку ми
чіпляємо і це питання так само і
досліджуємо його в мене таке відчуття що
українська армія
це не те до чого ще декілька років тому
у переважной більшості населення України
і в тому числі
в мене ну я маю на увазі точно до 14-го
року було таке враження що ну служитель
ті
хто нічого більше не може на жаль
і це теж частина була да такої
продуманою
ворожої війни
гібридною по
знищенню українського армії І власне
виникнення у суспільство такої конотації
де по відношенню до власне армії що це
ну
такі невдахи всі переважно Хіба ми
можемо зараз так подумати про нашу армію
ні
ми ж бачимо що наша західний партнери
надають чи сучасної засоби
ведення бою різноманітного дивуються
ті здатності українців так швидко
опановувати і досягати таких результатів
які навіть не можуть досягнути саміх
творці
цих
сучасних видів озброєння ви сказали що з
роками ставлення змінюється думки
змінюються погляди у 2019 році ви якось
публічно критикували тодішнього вже
президента Зеленського за серіал Свати
за участю цих зйомках російського актора
добронравова А що це таке
демонстрації цього серіалу що це таке
бізнес на крові
тобто ніхто не приховує що і нікому не
соромно що
один з головних акторів відкрито
підтримає окупацію Крим
не соромно за ці роки ваша ваша візія
президенти його вчинків ця візія
змінилася Так
я не відмовляюсь від своїх слів Я і
зараз переконую що будь-яку справу має
вести Професіонал я надзвичайно поважаю
Петра Олексійовича Порошенка 5-го
президента України шостий Президентом
України у мене була
до того як він став президентом така
власна історія
гідності 25 квартал провів середнього
спека кварталу були продюсерами однієї з
моїх стрічок чемпіони з підворіддя
і момент
[музика]
здачі фільму
Між групою продюсерів і мною і
інвестором виникла
[музика]
Скажімо так доволі емоційно суперечка
стосовно присутності української гімну
Наприкінці
фільму хоча це виходило із логіки події
які про які розповідаються стрічки ти
весь цей час Володимир Олександрович
мовчав
коли я вже
зрозумів що моє аргументи ніяким чином
не діють
я сказав що
[музика]
звернувшись до
присутніх в кімнаті що
ну власне
гроші
ваші
матеріали так само належить вам
Я готовий передати але ми його прізвище
не буде в титрах як режисера Це був 12-й
рік і вже готовий був увійти і тут слово
взяв Володимир Олександрович
і звернувшись до всіх сказав буду
український гімн
він сказав це так що ніхто сперечатися
настав він не був тоді президентом
але я відчув що людина
з твердими переконаннями які які мені
відгукуються потім були вибори
і звичайно я не зрозумів цього
і звичайно як тоді так і зараз
переконаний в тому що
кожною справою має займатися
професіоналом але напевно так було
в цьому задум Всевишнього Я нікого не
ідеалізую
не збираюсь це робити
але зараз у мене багато причин
аргументованих принаймні для мене точно
гордитися своїм президентом але і не
треба мовчати
коли ти бачиш прикольний в тому що є
речі які не можуть
принаймні існувати і в майбутньому
нагальність обговорення і критики влади
вона на часі під час повномасштабної
війни Якщо це не викликає ризики
руйнування
не дай боже армії або взаємовідносини
між армією та і
виконавчою владою Якщо це не підриває
самі Базіс для існування держави Ну
звичайно про це треба говорити
і якщо щось пов'язано з
[музика]
вчиненні злочинів тим більше під час
військового часу не відворотність
Покарання має бути просто
знову ж таки базісною невідворотною
річчю за останній рік рік
повномасштабної війни суспільство таким
не мовчало в контексті деяких
корупційних репутаційних скандалів з
держкіно суспільство абсолютно не
мовчало те що відбувається зараз там
які у нас проблеми з цією структурою що
з нею не так
якщо зануритися взагалі в історію
взаємовідносин
кіно митців зокрема і
державної структури держкіно то ви точно
зможете побачити щоб все своє існування
така структура як я як
державного Комітет з підтримки на кінні
фотографії завжди був хедлайнером
створення
таких емоційних територій на якої дуже
багато емоцій чимало фактів Да і так
далі але
знову ж таки я не хочу нікого
ідеалізувати або демолізувати якщо Ну
немає підстав це майже завжди так було
не вибудовує
чіткої прозорої
структури комунікації і це стосується не
тільки держкіно
комунікація між
громадянами Да і державною структурою
коли потрібно не тільки йти попереду да
А ще і формувати
контекст
і він з одного боку цілком зрозуміли де
наш український контекст Ми ж не можемо
сказати що
є конкретні факти доведені слідством і
судом там руйнування знищення з боку
цієї державної інституції
Всі ми знаємо історію з центром Довженка
Я не вірю що хто-небудь в Україні
взагалі наважиться
щось зробити по відношенню до архіву
українського кіно культура є фундаментом
базісом середовищем
на якому народжуються в якому зростає
отримує освіту уявлення про світ
цінності сенси кожна людина якщо ми
хочемо
верховенство права і дотримання букви
закону і непідкупності є королівський
британський суд
ми маємо
виховувати таких майбутніх
суддів самого дитинства їхнього в
Україні яке має бути українське кіно
зараз і після перемоги різноманітним
різножанровим професійним професійним
сенсі зроблено професійно тому що класно
професійно зроблений контент це є
патріотизм
має бути різних жанрів має бути
гуманістичним з чітким українським
контекстом з чітковою візою
і з чітким розумінням цільової аудиторії
які фільми ви поставили в приклад
як режисери і Наталка ворожбіти
драматурки сценарист цей
багато-багато моїх інших колег які
роблять дійсно класно українське кіно
різні жанрів
різних напрямків то мета українського
кіно яка зараз
зараз мета
то вона напевно що і немає змінюватися
ніколи мета говорити людини про людину
мета Все ж таки
бути територією так романтизованою Так
утопічною але територією де
самі світли світлі почуття
людини
мають підтвердження
права свою існування і право своєї
перемоги над всім тим ні з ким що в
людині і в кожному з нас є а інакше
навіщо Мистецтво це неправда але в
ідеальному випадку може стати
неправдою яка допомагає зрозуміти правду
Давайте робити це
Дякую вам за це розмову